okie dokie carlu demora en kill yan yeah
the last game I remember that was a
pretty awful loss going back to my usual
sloth defense and see what is coming up
with this one yeah only today I looked
at a for a little bit oh we place this
Wow and it looks strange that good for
white that's a huge advantage in space
so Bishop here on a very good day white
gets a night 285 and just wins this game
let's see how good a day that is today
hmm I asked to do something active I
don't know what but night h5 this one
yeah I guess that's not correct that's
not not good per se but maybe a good
decision for blitz chess so can I do
this keeping keeping the pawn probably
check
so let's see you not just III here
probably
can I get a nice to see five ok that a
DM just went out of the window
see one
that's difficult to planes not at all
easy
it has two ideas possible Bishop d3 on
93
does you really just want to take that
maybe
he just wanted to take it ok so if I go
F for here just protect it like that we
take the 9700 Bishop c7
how do I continue though maybe f form
then be three something to the C file
King up Brooksie one trying to do
something against that pawn the moment
is not easily winning the b6 bond if I
go before at some point he always have
see form or other capture of course and
in some cases ok I want that extra
protection and maybe be three next be
three can you go like 94 looks wrong I
can probably move the bishop
okay Brooke see one next yes but I
didn't really see what what that leads
to saw the idea but I didn't get it I'd
be sick things but anyway anyway
okay can take d for next move right b6
and taking on g form i can take c5
actually if I am very slow I can take c
5 6 yeah just route before doesn't
really have a great square for that
Bishop c7 but that's answered baby
should be three
now that looks good forward it looks
good for what if it takes a five what do
I play group b 6i guess I'll check okay
check
okay I'll even the score him he was plus
one before that game now I cannot
protect the Queen side those bishops are
bit too strong black resins jam I was an
interesting defense with that pond i
would add peace sacrifice i think that
this is this is very questionable for
black this kind of thing yeah after
Queen B 6 there is a well-known game
Boris Gelfand with white against
Alexander Milosevic which was the same
idea maybe the precise maybe the exactly
the same thing I'm not sure it was very
similar to that and yeah like really
have some has problems here I really
want to look that up wait I've got a
book here where that game is featured
was it was very comparable
hmm that's cute it's exactly the same
position mm-hmm Devon plate III though
instead of Bishop f4 it looks a bit less
tempting but he wanted to speed up this
procedure yeah that's true yeah Bishop
f4 looks good yeah if he does not do
that which it means it's probably not
objectively right but I understand the
point it's just easier to play in this
blitz situation after the P sacrifice um
yeah if you place slowish moves like
let's say he does that I go here
councilman c3 yeah and now well I'm on
my way and if I hit a 5 with the night
he can just resign the whole thing this
is not a very good endgame just quite
one-sided the computer only gives white
a slight advantage but I don't buy it i
think white is much better him i came so
he took it and I went here keeping
changa and porn for the moment gym
around here I mean I think he played it
well it was it was interesting yeah I
hear my doubts I think it's a piece and
he doesn't get get to be 6 i'm really
i'm not one hundred percent sure but i
think i'm quite heavily favored here to
to win that now night here back at six
yeah i took me about two to see that and
yeah he really has no no good option
this move on Bishop c5 i can just drop
back and it's a piece for two points but
it's still a piece and here this is
essentially winning now as this is
answered by Bishop e3 and he lose
everything check him that was check just
prolonging prolonging the proceedings
yeah and i'm content i think the buzzer
was a good game okay well thanks for
watching